pour en parler j'accueille sur ce
plateau Franck Riester bonjour je vous
souhaite le ministre en charge des
relations avec le Parlement la gauche
sénatoriale on l'a entendu ce matin à
dénonce un coup de force historique
contre le Parlement avec l'utilisation
de ce 44 3 sur cette réforme des
retraites qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez non c'est pas du tout un coup
de force on a entendu effectivement des
mots comme coup de force coup d'État qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce qui se passe
ce qui se passe c'est que le
gouvernement souhaite la clarté des
débats souhaite éviter l'obstruction et
utilise une disposition de la
Constitution française qui est notre
règle la plus notre règle suprême en
matière de droit pour veiller à ce que
ils puissent y avoir le temps d'aller au
fond des débats et cet article 44-3 a
déjà été utilisé dans le passé encore il
y a pas si longtemps sur le quinquennat
de François Hollande ici
au Sénat c'est ce vote unique qui permet
à
aux députés ils comptent au sénateur de
l'opposition pardon de pouvoir présenter
leurs amendements simplement on fera
qu'un seul vote sur le texte tel qu'il
est voté discuter voté jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et ensuite tel qu'il est
prévu par le gouvernement plus les
amendements pour lequel pour lesquels le
Gouvernement émet un avis favorable il y
aura un vote à la fin donc de cette
discussion que ça laissera évidemment
tout le temps au sénateur de s'exprimer
de proposer de défendre et
éventuellement de critiquer les
dispositions de cette texte de loi
finale les sénateurs de gauche ne vont
faire que présenter leurs amendements il
n'y aura pas de vote sur ces amendements
de la gauche finalement qu'un vote final
sur des amendements sélectionnés triez
sur le volet par le gouvernement est-ce
que votre utilisation du 44-3 c'est pas
un échec démocratique non les chèques
démocratique c'est l'obstruction alors
que ça fait plus de 70 heures je crois
74 heures de débats ici au Sénat qui
nous reste encore 30 heures il y a une
série de sous-amendements en permanence
qui sont déposés par les sénateurs de
l'opposition pour n'ont pas aller au
fond des textes du texte mais ralentir
les débats et ça va permettre la clarté
justement de ces débats quand on dépose
70 amendements de suppression d'un
article alors que un groupe politique
peut en faire un expliquer pourquoi il
souhaite que cet article soit supprimé
pas obligé d'en faire 70 quand il y a
toute une série d'amendements sur le
même sujet en simplement bougeant la
date pour par exemple une remise de
rapport qui fait des dizaines des
centres et voir parfois des centaines
d'amendements tout ça est de
l'obstruction c'est une technique
d'obstruction avérée et le gouvernement
veut éviter cette obstruction pour
permettre le débat justement et c'est ce
que donc nous faisons avec l'utilisation
de cet article 44-3 pour un vote unique
Franck rester on va se projeter un peu
sur la suite de l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites il devrait donc
avec ce 44 3 avoir un vote de la
majorité de droite et du centre pour
cette réforme des retraites ensuite il y
aura ce qu'on appelle la commission
mixte paritaire c'est à dire une réunion
dans une salle entre 7 députés cette
sénateurs pour trouver une version
commune de cette réforme vous pensez que
cette commission mixte paritaire peut AB
un accord je le pense je l'espère et
ensuite une fois que il y a cet accord
sur ce texte il y a le vote des
conclusions de la CMP conclusive qui
doit avoir lieu jeudi matin si la CMP
qui devrait se tenir mercredi et
conclusive jeudi matin au Sénat et je
dis après midi à l'Assemblée nationale
effectivement petite précision de
procédure parlementaire c'est le Sénat
qui examinerait en premier justement
cette version commune de la réforme des
retraites c'est assez inédit notamment
pour un texte budgétaire est-ce que ça
veut dire que vous voulez utiliser et
bien finalement le vote de la droite
sénatoriale pour convaincre les députés
LR qui seraient encore récalcitrant
concernant cette réforme pour avoir une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et
éviter un 49-3 non simplement que vous
avez besoin de temps à l'Assemblée
nationale pour finir les discussions du
projet de loi nucléaire jeudi matin et
c'est pour ça qu'on a décalé à jeudi
après-midi la discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale multiplication technique juste
une dernière question est-ce que vous
craignez l'utilisation d'être obligé
d'utiliser un 49,3 l'Assemblée nationale
sans majorité nous voulons avoir un vote
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est pour ça que nous avons écouté les
oppositions écouter les organisations
syndicales modifier notre notre texte
nous sommes toujours et encore à
l'écoute et nous souhaitons qu'il y ait
au-delà de la majorité présidentielle
majorité plus large pour voter cette
réforme essentielle qui permet de sauver
notre système de retraite par
répartition ce que la droite a toujours
défendu et vous pensez la voir à ce
moment où on se parle cette majorité
plus large nous y travaillons et nous
continuons d'y travailler merci beaucoup
merci Franck Riester d'être venu sur le
plateau de public